you'll never stop burning pac-man no
matter how much you support the
establishment you will never stop them
pac-man right yeah well I supported
Bernie not the establishment so there's
someone who thinks bernie is a shoo-in
and then here's Jimmy from Philly an
angry vicious trumpet who every once in
a while stumbles across some
uncontroversial minor truth Jimmy from
Philly thinks Bernie has no shot
whatsoever take a listen Gary Jim Bowie
I'm gonna tell you how your life's just
gonna go and you know I'm not a college
graduate I'm not an economics major like
you
that's the years we love the poorly
educated just like Donald Trump what's
gonna happen there's no freakin way on
God's green earth that your boy Bernie
will get nominated it's just not going
to happen in ask room some kind of way
he knows how they're gonna do it but
they're gonna do it all right so there
are two conflicting views about the
Bernie candidacy one caller believes
there's no stopping Bernie the other
caller believes there's no way that
Bernie gets the nomination we will soon
know by the time you listen to this
voicemail we may already know the answer
to this question we have a really good
bonus show for you today
in Alabama schools there is a major
debate over whether yoga should be part
of gym class why is there a debate I
believe that the reason may not surprise
you but you should be appalled by it we
will also talk about in the midst of
everything that's going on right now
with the virus and everything else
Donald Trump thinks what we need are tax
cuts we need tax cuts why and what
exactly would that do we will discuss it
and also Montana Governor Steve Bullock
has announced that he is going to run
for Senate now if you watched the
presidential campaign you may find this
quite interesting we've talked a lot
about hey there are some people around
whose time would be better spent whose
energy would be better invested running
for Senate Steve Bullock is doing that
and we will talk about it on today's
bonus show get instant access to the
bonus show at join pakman.com or
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show